oh you do I trusted in a litter Oh what
is going on YouTube now I know a lot you
may or may not be surprised that I am a
huge advocate of improving yourself
through Andrew Casey on that Spanish you
dumbass adapted anything
I think that's fry something I can read
you know what I would school one of the
most difficult things that I had to deal
with was improving my grades more
importantly it's time to get into the
college and about it
it was really difficult to even find a
reason they even approve my dreams I
think the reason why a lot of us had
problems getting better grades because
nobody put it too expensive
or why we need them but y'all we know
what it is LGI baby let's get next you
got to realize why you get bad grades in
the first place first to stay you know
that what's finance kiddie class that
very studies he gets straight A's
and you think you could do the same look
at your dumb ass it don't work like that
it's just the gift that they had that we
weren't born with it doesn't mean that
they're smarter than us
it's just we got a lot of incentive
think sons of [ __ ] for some reason
has teens that you sit down and study
[ __ ] without having any of you distract
them which I still can't do that until
this day let me tell you something when
I wasn't team anything that remotely
resembled an ass or a titty and I was
done [ __ ] what you looking at down oh
this damn oranges [ __ ] give me some
juice boys taking your stick you know
this still amazing each other's dick how
teams can sit down and focus without
thinking the crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] in Moscow
happen students fail because their
all-time be rappers but they couldn't
read all right I just had this read that
failed in the class because he would
took everything he learned and put it to
a gangster rap but didn't get all the
information wrong all right class today
we're gonna learn about Abraham Lincoln
Abraham with your chocolate cherry tree
down [ __ ] that's why you really [ __ ]
up don't watch it ain't got a bullet in
his head oh that's not it MIT Romney you
elected piston [ __ ] go home second
mistake do what you have to do
first they do what you want to do after
trust me anything might be when it comes
to study you will do what you want to do
a lot longer than what you're supposed
to be doing get off your computer stop
touching yourself and get study and
after you watch this video let me tell
you something here Harry Potter your
magical wand will be there for you to
follow all day after you're done with
your math problems after you're done
with your getting rich you can go ahead
and tickle your elbow later you do the
advice you first you do that [ __ ] a lot
longer and the stuff that you want to do
by that time it's already today
you're a tide of [ __ ] you would just
touch yourself to watch your end of the
corner all day not super personal
experience that is nasty
what am I saying let me put this in
perspective for you do you know why you
want to get good grades unless you got
some random ass telling some dope-ass
skill are you rich
you gonna be broke as [ __ ] can't gum the
ball Oh read a book [ __ ] can't sink
your [ __ ] go to school [ __ ] can't rap
save your life learn to read [ __ ] it's
cool to be the class clown now huh but
just wait to you all then you got two
kids Sephora do you want to be that
dumbass dead that gets mad at his kids
when he can't answer question daddy
what's two plus two
two - Oh to hell with that two plus two
is where you chuck hello go to your room
Bobby daddy don't know [ __ ] if anything
for those of you that don't give a [ __ ]
about an education fine that's your deal
but I'm telling you right now improving
yourself mentally it's very important
but if it's not going to be schooled and
it better be something else to do to put
your time and effort to make sure that
you have a promising and brighter future
and if you can't figure that out then
you might as well put your time and
effort into education and what those
other please don't save on you stupid
ass examples like well Alba I didn't
like your school [ __ ] you a nice time
when you can figure out the theory of
relativity by no damn self you come up
to me and say that [ __ ] letter e equals
MC [ __ ] to [ __ ] up before you get
slapped with a bag of nickels my friends
do not just other people has an excuse
because
you are not them but if you choose to
continue your education or not I suggest
you still take your time to improve
yourself mentally and stimulate your
mind every now and then I know school is
a [ __ ] toy but trust me heaven and
education will give you a bit of an
upper hand in life it's just how it is
so my friends take some time and
stimulate your mind to be 15 minutes
think about that [ __ ] guys I like that
hey what's going on people I got
something really exciting to tell y'all
now back in the day I used to go to
school don't say [ __ ] but we all know
that aside from your tuition event the
biggest hit your wallet were obviously
your textbooks
I was actually contacted by this website
called slug books calm if you haven't
heard of them
thank you later [ __ ] the website
actually looks like this right here so
take a look and you can actually go
ahead and click the website link in the
description box below if you want to go
ahead and check out the website and if
you forgot already it's gonna be right
below our video anyways all right yeah
so let's go ahead and get to it what
does slug books do exactly [ __ ] books
com compares your textbook prices that
you buy from your bookstore
competitor other websites such as Amazon
you have to do is go ahead and tell slug
books what course you're in and what
school you go to and then it'll go ahead
and tell you what books you need for the
cheapest prices for those courses so
basically what I'm telling you is that
slug books will save you money on your
textbooks you don't know if that hundred
dollar book that you're gonna buy it can
be $10 somewhere else probably the
dopest thing about this website is the
fact that it doesn't sell you anything
it's just a reference point for you to
go ahead and figure out which books you
can get for cheaper somewhere else
go ahead get you can't and go buy
textbooks for cheap price and save that
money because we all know Asian parents
love it when you save money if anything
your parents might already know about
this website just waiting for you to go
ahead and make the right choice so don't
get your ass whooped I read books to
[ __ ] names so starting out what kara
but I'm here to help y'all out my hands
and those mistake and you Spanish again
I don't watch my new stench if your
child does do that now when he becomes
rich can you hook me up with a job I
snorted with the foot